Oliver Stone is one of the most
controversial directors alive today he's
making a movie about drugs kidnapping
and torture is gonna get nasty
sandwiches is directed by Oliver Stone
as I said it has Blake Lively as this
chick who gets kidnapped he's two
boyfriends that she has and they're
actually like it's like a love triangle
like they're together they're all
together and they know about it like
they're totally aware of the fact that
they're both with this hot chick and she
likes both of them the film explains out
of this opening narration by Blake
Lively and she's just kind of
introducing everyone get Taylor Kitsch
she's like this really hardcore guy who
just beats up everyone basically but his
friend Aaron Johnson is like this
botanist guy he's really smart and
everything and both of them make and
sell drugs to a whole bunch of people
and they've gotten rich off of it and he
got Benicio del Toro and Salma Hayek I
know these two people who work for this
other big drug company and they want to
work with them when that doesn't go
right they kidnap their girlfriend Blake
Lively and then it gets nasty now I will
say this title for this movie savages is
like the best title they could have
picked because this movie is pretty
intense and when I say intense I mean
there's a dude with an eyeball hanging
out of his head in this movie that being
said this is actually a really
interesting film and I got into the
story this movie I like the performances
in this movie I like the way that the
actors worked off from each other and I
like the way the story moved along
before I talk about any actors let's
just address the elephant in the room
his name is Taylor Kitsch he was in John
Carter and battleship this year he's
basically doing the exact same thing
he's very dry he's very serviceable
there's nothing you can really pinpoint
about his performance that's awful but
there's also really nothing you can
pinpoint about it that's good you know
he's just he works for this movie though
I will say that the character he plays
is a hardened quiet guy who was affected
by war and so his performance that he
gives kind of fits his character but
it's just it's really the same
performance that have seen him given to
other movies this year so I'm aware of
the fact that he's not really getting
like a great performance
that's just Taylor Kitsch Erin Johnson
from kick-ass he did a pretty good job
in this movie I liked his character he's
really the character in this movie that
we as the audience relate to more
because even though he's in the middle
of this organization and
been around it for a long time he's not
a murderer he's not a killer he doesn't
do any of the stuff to Taylor Kitsch
does so he's constantly surprised by all
the things that he sees in this movie so
we kind of go through him Blake Lively
nice-looking girl I just don't buy her
really that much as an actress I thought
she did well in the town but she was
playing like a HO bag I'm leaving
that in and then savages she kind of
plays the same character because she's
addicted to drugs since the eighth grade
she has two boyfriends they're in like
this mutual love triangle where they're
all just fine with it like and she's
basically that same character except in
the town she clearly was broken up about
that lifestyle and didn't want to be
like that anymore in this movie she just
totally except above it she was all
right in the film okay I'm there's a lot
of performances in this movie that we're
just fine
there isn't a performance really that I
just thought was bad or anything but
really the main three actors Aaron
Johnson was the best now let's get to
the people in this movie here were great
Benicio del Toro dude that guy is creepy
as heck in this movie like every time he
came in a room I was like what is he
gonna do he's gonna cuff a finger at Oh
what's it gonna do now menacing creepy
like I actually bought that that is like
a nasty disgusting just scum of the
earth person and he played it really
well
Salma Hayek great here this is one of
the better performances I've actually
seen from her I really liked one of the
things that she did her dialogue mixed
Spanish with English and that's really
what happens with people who are
speaking English but another language is
their native tongue when they get mad
they start speaking in their native
tongue and she did that along this movie
and I really liked how they did it with
the movie it's it worked well I thought
she did a really good job and let me
just say she is 45 I looked that up
aging beautifully seriously not bad
Salma Hayek it is really nice to see
John Travolta in a movie that's not old
dogs he's really good in this movie I
really liked him in this movie I thought
he did a great job Dhruv Ulta has these
great mannerisms as an actor you know he
just says stuff sometimes and he gets
really intense he gets kind of freaked
out and he just spurts out all bunch of
dialogue he does that a lot in this
movie and I really liked him and so it
reminded me a Broken Arrow never broken
arrow Scott Dane what a rush
I was invested in this story this movie
I liked where it was going
and then the ending happened you know
that metaphor people say the rug got
pulled out from under you imagine that
that actually happened to you you're
actually standing on a rug and some
douchebag behind you takes a rug and
just goes boom and just pulls it and you
like flip upwards and land and break
your neck
that's pretty much standing in this
movie it is one of the biggest bait and
switches I've ever seen in a movie it
was very disappointing I don't know what
happened and I started thinking about it
it's Oliver Stone movie he always wants
to be controversial he thrives on being
controversial in his films almost all of
his films are very much that way and the
whole movie I was thinking is this
really the only thing is going to do
that's controversial let's make it kind
of violent and then the ending happened
I went ahh yes okay I understand now it
looks like the movie was going in a
progressive way and then all of a sudden
he just went you know what how about we
just kind of rewind and do the most
conventional thing we could possibly do
how about that the ending really took
this movie down a notch but here's the
dilemma I'm really facing I liked almost
the entire movie you know and it's just
this one part of it that made it not as
good I was thinking a B throughout the
whole movie and I'm gonna give it a
b-minus because of the ending it knocked
it down a grade it was a good movie it
was entertaining all the way through
performances were mostly good and the
story was interesting that's really what
matters when you watch a movie over that
last section of the story ah so what's
your favorite Oliver Stone movie what do
you guys think and do you think that
Taylor Kitsch is just going to have
another box-office flop with this one
since the other two films that came out
this year not so great and now this one
is opening with spider-man and as always
guys if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck my
eyes